merci la parole est à notre collègue
Alexandre wiisi pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et
républicain merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Intérieur le 6 décembre à l'Élysée il
a été porté atteinte au principe de
séparation des Églises et de l'État un
ministre du culte en l'espèce le grand
Rabin de France a allumé la première
bougie d'anoua dans la salle des fêtes
du palais présidentiel en présence du
chef de l'État ceci est radicalement
contraire à la Constitution au principes
qui nous fondent au principe qui nous
lit et au fait que le Président de la
République en est le garant monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur ma question elle
est finalement assez simple dans l'Oise
il y a quelques jours nous avons rendu
hommage à Ferdinand Buisson nous avons
dit que la religion libre dans l'état
libre c'était la règle qui nous sur
laquelle nous nous
retrouvions comment peut-on imaginer que
le Président de la République
aujourd'hui ait commis un tel impère par
rapport aux règles de laïcité comment
peut-on aujourd'hui vous faire confiance
lorsque la première ministre depuis
Mayotte nous dit qu'il s'agit là
simplement d'un soutien à la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur on ne combat pas
l'anti on ne combat pas l'antisémitiste
avec des offices religieux pouvez-vous
pouvez-vous s'il vous plaît nous
confirmer que il n'y aura pas de messe
de Noël à Matignon cette année qu'il n'y
aura pas de rupture du jeûne au
printemps au ministère de l'Intérieur
pouvez-vous nous dire que les palais de
la République ne seront pas le lieu
d'office cultuel pouvez-vous tout
simplement nous dire que c'était un
accident et non un précédent je vous
[Applaudissements]
merci